حسنًا ، تقول الصحافة المرتبطة
إنهم ناشدوا الحكومة الإسرائيلية
للحصول على مزيد من المعلومات حول
سبب عمل صحفييهم في المبنى
مع
شكاوى مستهدفة أيضًا من قناة الجزيرة ،
وقالت الحكومة الإسرائيلية إنها
استهدفت المبنى
بسبب وجود منشآت عسكرية
تابعة لجيش حماس.
عمليات استخباراتية ، هذا
ما يقوله المسؤولون الإسرائيليون إنهم
يقولون إنهم يبذلون
قصارى جهدهم لتجنب
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين ، وقد أعطوهم تحذيرًا مسبقًا
حتى يتمكن الجميع من إخلاء
المبنى بالفعل ، وكان هذا شيئًا
كرره رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو عندما كان لديه هاتف
في محادثة
في وقت متأخر من اليوم مع الرئيس بايدن ،
قال
إنه عرض الإجراءات التي
اتخذوها ضد
حماس ومجموعات أخرى في غزة ، كما
قال
وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي ، بيني غانز
، إنه تم التخطيط لمزيد من الإجراءات
ضد حماس
حماس من وجهة نظرهم.  هددوا
بالرد على  استهداف ذلك
المبنى الذي يسكنه صحفيون
يقولون إنهم سيستهدفون تل أبيب
خلال اليوم الذي استهدفوا فيه تل أبيب
بضربات صاروخية متعددة معظم تلك
الصواريخ التي أسقطتها صواريخ القبة الدفاعية الحديدية ،
لكن صاروخين قد مروا عبر
رجل إسرائيلي يبلغ من العمر 50 عامًا.
قُتل عندما سقط أحد تلك الصواريخ
في حي سكني
في الليل أه في
غزة هناك مخاوف من
احتمال حدوث هجوم معلوماتي متزايد
بسبب هذا الهجوم بالذات
على مبنى الصحفي الذي
سيدخل بالتأكيد في بقية
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع مخاوف من أن
الدبلوماسية  لا تسير بخطى كبيرة بما فيه الكفاية
على الرغم من زيادة مشاركة الرئيس بايدن في
حديثه مع
رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
محمود عباس وكذلك أن وتيرة
الدبلوماسية التي
لا تفتح الباب لا
تزال مفتوحة أمام رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
والحكومة الإسرائيلية لمواصلة
ضرباتهم.  ضد
حماس رئيس الوزراء مشيرا الى دعم من
جانب الولايات المتحدة  الدول لتكون قادرة على
الرد
على الهجمات القادمة من غزة نيك
روبرتسون CNN أشدود
إسرائيل